hallo leute das ist kelsey sie ist fünf
meter groß und kommt aus kalifornien
erinnert ihr euch letztes jahr waren wir
an der uci santa barbara in kalifornien
und da waren wir an deiner schule und
wir haben klasse kennen gelernt und
damals haben wir gesagt und janosch hat
gesagt wenn ihr mal nach berlin kommen
wollten praktikum machen dann meldet uns
euch bei uns und wer das gemacht
jetzt ist klar sie hier sie macht ein
praktikum bei uns und sie wollte
unbedingt auch eine sehr wichtige frage
auf der straße stellen kennt sich das
ist deine chance was fragst du heute wie
heißt du diese frau habe noch nie
gestellt wir sind noch nie drauf
gekommen
dafür musste erst kennen sich aus
kalifornien kommen kennst du hier ist
ein mikrofon
danke
[Musik]
wie heißen sie ingrid schütz und wie
gefällt dir deine neue ihre namen es
geht so etwas altbacken und ist diese
name einer familienname oder kommt es
seine tante also die schwester meiner
mutter hat den gleichen vornamen ingrid
und das war eine einnahme der wurde sehr
gerne in den 30er jahren an mädchen
gegeben wegen ingrid bergman die war
damals eine ein fernseh star
darum heißt wurde der hat hat sie den
wahrscheinlich verliehen bekommen und
meinen eltern ist nichts besseres
eingefallen beziehungsweise wir wollten
die regina nennen das fällt mir gerade
ein
aber das hat meinem vater nicht gefallen
wie heißt du ich heiße rita rosa jesaja
elias raffael
und wie gefällt ihr alle von ihren namen
wie uns die namen gefallen
also ich mag meinen namen sehr denn rita
rosa klingt schön und ich finde dass
meine beiden enkel auch sehr schöne
namen haben wie heißt du und wie gefällt
dir deinen namen wie heißt du ich heiße
gesine und die gefällt dir dann auch ich
mag meinen namen total gerne weil er
selten ist wie heißt du
und wie gefällt dir diese name ganz okay
es halt sehr traditionell und wie weißt
du wie deine familie auf diese name
gekommen ist ja meine mutter also meine
mutter steht auf russischen rocksängerin
liza deswegen hat mich so genannt und du
hast nie irgendwann gewünscht eine dame
zu wachsen
ich habe noch einen ersten namen den
sage ich aber nicht und das ist schon
mein zweiter name und ich bin wirklich
sehr zufrieden damit
und weißt du wie deine eltern da
rausgekommen sind ich glaube meine
mutter hat eine kollegin gehabt oder so
die gesehene auch hieß und mein papa hat
halt den ersten namen ausgewählt und ist
ganz furchtbar
da hat meine mama hat einen guten namen
dahinter geschoben und bestimmt dass das
mein rufname wird und dann werden sie
mir deine nachname auch sagen ja kühne
kühne also kühn ist ja bald quasi oder
halt ja doch klappt bruder fränk also
wenn man halt so kühn ist dann ist man
mutig und geradeaus und so ich heiße
kann ich heiße wird die schön und wie
gefällt dir ihre namen
eigentlich ganz gut ja also mein vorname
ist bettina das machte ich nicht aber
betty ist gut dass er mittlerweile
liebig männer und sie haben kinder ja
ich habe drei kindern das ist meine
nicht und meine zweite tochter
wie hast du ihre namen aus die älteste
ist katharina deshalb waren name der mir
schon immer gefallen hat und im
nachhinein habe ich erfahren dass das
die nummer eins in dem jahr war dann
hätte ich ihn nicht gewählt
bei lucia das war der vater oder den
ausgesucht hat zweiter und mirko war ein
name also der dritte heißt mirco das ist
ein slawischer name heißt der friedliche
den habe ich geträumt
sehr schön und hat dir irgendwann
gewünschte ihre namen zu wachsen ja als
kind als kind wollte ich immer jasmin
heißt unsere gegenwart ist also ziemlich
simple geschichte genau
ja ja ich weiß auch um einen anderen
namen trägt oder so ja aber auch
vielleicht gar nicht richtig schöne
auffallend früher
und wissen sie wie ihre name ausgewählt
waren von ihrer eltern ja unsere eltern
wollten die plätze namen haben
deswegen ist an der konstanz ist und
beides vornamen die darin vorkommen ich
kenne die beiden nicht aus der bibel
aber das war so die idee
und sie ist meine schwester bettchen
kommt dass der bibel diese arbeit also
mein vater dann haben sie mal ja aber
wenn sie dann weiß ich gar nicht also
einnahmen hatte durfte sich mama
ausdenken aus einer der papa aussuchen
ich weiß gar nicht mehr was ausgesucht
hat keine ahnung
wie gefällt dir deinen armen schützen
haben einen spaten vorn haben und was
ist sein spitzname jeremias und das
finde ich viel neugier sah ja wie heißt
du und wie gefällt dir deinen armen
mainau
da habe ich noch nie groß darüber
nachgedacht aber ich finde das haben
meine eltern ganz okay entschieden
und weißt du wie deine eltern auf diese
namen gekommen sind nicht das weiß ich
nicht aber ich weiß was der name
bedeutet also ja also als löwe also leon
oder im französischen lyon und ist eine
abkürzung von etwas oder leonhard wäre
der längere aber leon ist in deutschland
sehr also in der kurzform beliebter name
und hast du irgendwann gewünscht seine
name zu wechseln
ja so was hört zu marie also zu einem
deutschen namen passt irgendwie nicht
wohlgefühlt mit diesem namen
also als viele leute haben halt
vorurteile wenn sie all gehören deswegen
ja was für welche vorurteile so eine
kräftige eine starke organ bin ich halt
nicht dass du wirst nicht schätzen dass
du doch schon aber halt nicht körperlich
wie mental
wie heißen sie annette und wie gefällt
sie ihre namen früher nicht so jetzt
ganz in ordnung und so früher haben sie
gewünscht
ihre namen wachsen unbedingt katharina
oder stephan ohm wissen sie wie ihre
eltern auf diese name weiß ich nicht es
ist nicht deine familie name habe ich
nicht und früher gab es sollte in deiner
klassen oder so was die die gleiche name
nur 40 jährige frauen so eine
altmodische haben wir das halt mir gut
habe ich hab ich nun nicht nur habe
nichts daran auszusetzen gefällt mir gut
ist dass der familienname oder haben
andere leute in deine familie diese
abnahme auch den namen christoph haben
meiner familie eigentlich niemand man
kommt einfach mal so dann wissen sie wie
ihre eltern diese name ausgewählt haben
ja ich bin kurz vor weihnachten geboren
das kam von christopher aus dem
christusträger und sie haben keine
kinder wurde
überlegen sie jetzt irgendwelche ganz
toll ja eher altmodische das gefällt
ihnen besser
ja es nicht weiß nicht jeder hat ja er
ist selbst immer namens kasse
entschieden sie dann mit ihrem mann auf
an irgendeinen also wir haben uns schon
entschieden
aber ich verrate ich finde meinen namen
sehr schön auch raphael beil erinnert
mich an meine lieblings personen ja
tackles und ja kennst du bist zurück ich
will jetzt unbedingt wissen war diese
frage ergiebig ja schon ein bisschen wir
haben viele interessante antworten
bekommen
was war dein lieblings name jedem halt
gesagt dieser reserve des tores
das fand ich toll und hast du viele so
typische namen gefunden oder auch so
regionalen amt nicht ganz so viele
moderne nahm es gab eigentlich mehrere
altmodische namen recht ja was denn
charlotte nein ich kann mich nicht daran
erinnern aber und gab es viele
amerikanischen haben hier in deutschland
die chance nein nein die zeiten wo alle
leute ihre kinder kevin genannt haben
nach kevin allein zu haus sind schon
wieder vorbei nein es war mehr ich mich
so namen von die bibel und religion den
namen wirklich ein paar yahoo er
schreibt uns doch mal was ihr dachtet
dazu was sind eure antworten
wir freuen uns auf eure meinung die
kommen in die kommentare und wenn ihr
lust habt übungen zu machen jede woche
schreiben wir richtige übungsblätter zu
unserer episoden das heißt zehn seiten
mit blättern wo ihr nochmal vokabeln
geben könnt ihr könnt grammatische
übungen machen
zu den verschiedenen sachen die ihr in
dieser episode gehört habt das ganze
bekommt ihr für nur 1 euro pro woche bei
patchen also werde im übrigen patchen
damit unterstützt sie unsere arbeit und
liefert eine wichtige unterstützung das
ganze könnt ihr hier machen
hier könnt ihr abonnieren und nächste
woche könnt ihr natürlich der
einschalten du bist nächste woche noch
hier oder kennt sehen ja bin ich
bis bald china